good afternoon everyone I'm David
Madigan executive vice president and
Dean of the Faculty of Arts and Sciences
here at Columbia and it is my great
pleasure to welcome all of you to this
Columbia world leaders forum event were
honored today very honored to have the
President of the Republic of Namibia hey
gay gang gob here with us today the
president is accompanied by a delegation
of his staff and government leaders
including the Honorable nuh tembo Nandi
Nandita deputy prime minister and
minister of international relations and
cooperation first lady Monica Genghis
and also the Namibian ambassador and
other ministers this forum established
over a decade ago gives us the privilege
of learning about and learning about and
hearing about pivotal issues in public
policy and governance from the men and
women grappling with these challenges on
a daily basis the world leaders forum is
a remarkable space it's where we gather
to engage the issues we read about in
the headlines and our course readings
the refugee crisis climate change and
sustainability the need for transparency
in our global financial systems and
ongoing encounters with that grand
experiment democracy last year namibia
celebrated 25 years of independence and
democracy i'm certain we will all learn
much from President Jang Cobbs address
about his country's growth over the
course of those years here to introduce
the president is professor Jeffrey Sachs
qett let professor of sustainable
development and professor of Health
Policy and management he's also director
of the center for sustainable
development at Columbia as well as of
the sustainability development solutions
network this year professor Sachs
concluded a truly remarkable 14-year
term as director of the Earth Institute
the Earth Institute brings together the
brightest earth scientists economists
experts in public health business and
law to do critical research into the
forces that shape our planet and then to
integrate their discoveries into solving
Earth's many challenges to put those
challenges into context here is
Professor Sachs
good afternoon what a great honor it is
to have president gang job with us today
I was 14 years head of the Earth
Institute but he's been 15 years prime
minister of this country and president
and I would say the James Madison the
head of the Constitutional Assembly that
wrote the constitution of the country
and I would say the Thomas Jefferson
also who brought the world community
together to support the independence of
Namibia it's a remarkable remarkable
career and I'm so thrilled that I've
been able to know you and learn from you
and to admire your leadership for many
many years back to Harvard days and the
united nations and all during the period
of your prime ministership to prime
minister ships 1992 2002 and 2012 to
2015 Namibia is one of the star
performers of Africa it is absolutely
consistently rated at the top of the
charts for its democratic institutions
rule of law transparency its economy
grows much above the African average its
per capita income puts it near the top
of the charts in Africa none of this
should ever be taken for granted of
course none of this should be assumed
that that's a natural way because
unfortunately good governance is never a
natural way I think Namibia can be very
proud of all its presidents and its
leaders but I know that there's a very
special place and role that you have
played from well before independence
through independence through the
adoption of the Constitution and through
the history of your young country
so on behalf of all of us at Columbia
University it's a profound honor to have
you here we're very much looking forward
to your talk about good governance and
transparency this is based also on the
president's PhD research on good
governance and his scholarly research as
well as his practical experience it's a
remarkable and wonderful combination mr.
president thank you for being here
professor Sachs thank you very much so
wonderful introduction dr. David Madigan
professor Brandon ratan students of
Columbia University members of my
delegation joseph stiglitz i am always
fighting of the name but ladies and
gentlemen i am proud to be here you
share my views or namibia and africa at
one of the most prestigious universities
in the world when i was telling somebody
i'm going to i didn't say to give
lecture at columbia university i said
i'm going to give a talk at columbia
university that's at radius or not they
stood upon me but as I was saying that
there is neither invitation from Harvard
University so I'm going there also on
Wednesday so I am honored to talk to one
of the best universities in the world
let me express my profound sense to dr.
Madigan and all those who are involved
in making this visit possible you may
not be aware but the olden days I once
set here attending one summer school
classes so i could easily claim that i
was at Columbia to as many are doing
well as s for summer school but our acid
is yeah in early 60s today i'll talk
about constitutional democracy
governance and development reforms in
Africa to locate my topic I would like
to use the example of the organization
african unity 10 a you I regard
organization of african unity as
transactional organization it was there
to fight to free Africa well as a state
to state organization it didn't involve
the people but then we transform it to a
you and just to make an example I
retired a you transformational
organization in a sense that it involves
the people who have the Parliament pan
African Parliament we have what you call
now not regarding anymore state
sovereignty as sacrosanct we do
intervene when we feel that there is a
violation to one comes your violation of
Human Rights or unlawful entry into
power by presidents it will be a you and
shattuck and echo us who will be the
ones who will add and ostracize that
leader who would come through unlawful
means unlike in the past where other
Americans or British will be the ones to
condemn and edge how to do something it
is not us who are taking that action
that is very important because today I
was saying for Africans to be respected
and Africa to be respected Africans must
first respect themselves we must respect
ourselves we must know that we kill our
own people is not the way to go so if
you do that you can't expect the world
to respect you they will end up here and
tell you you are doing a wrong thing so
we are saying therefore it should be us
who must do that and we are doing that
now the African Union
is also more people sent that as I said
we have peace and security council and
Africans tent by force african bank
court of justice and so on however these
things are they are they function with
yoga by the structural functionalism to
the function as we put them on a paper
to say they are doing a be set so
there's a long way to go but one
important thing that I realized is a
special creation of a six region six
region was Africa at five regions and we
had a special region six written this
episode and that one is to cater for
diaspora yes / are not asked the ones
who left in slavery but yes but I
economic diaspora because there are many
Africans who are now living abroad we
don't also talk about brain drain any
longer we are talking about brain gain
so these Africans 10 brains Hills they
should bow back those skills to Africa
so episode is there and they are
supposed to be represented in our
episode today can also have an input in
decision-making of Africa but still it
had earlier stages not properly utilize
talking about Africa today and I went to
claim that Africa is now a new Africa
some of us although I am old in age I
regard myself as new African leader
Africa on the move and therefore we talk
about who's but also other aspect is
that we respect our former presidents
they live is a term limits now when they
leave their offices Jericho denies they
are respected back in Namibia we are
talking about kind of legacy legacy that
the founding father of revolutionary
father comrade same yama brought
fighting and bringing independence and
democracy and reconciling our people
followed through democratic elections by
second president mahama whom will
require a stabilizer and now i was to
call myself those truly who is now
charged providing now prosperity because
we have good Constitution we have
democracy but people do not eat those
things people are now saying after 26
years we when do now yet reason shell de
mer palaces but decent shelter jobs
clothing food infrastructure schools
clinics those are the things we want now
so show up for my party the elective
mean I was told I must not deal of the
question of poverty and corruption so I
will defer start first by talking about
provenance which I have started with we
are a fully fledged democracy as in
professor Sachs already touched on that
we are also having fundamentals welcome
to macroeconomic architecture and
definitely we our banking system is well
managed a world-class banking system and
our is professor said already gross
weight was about five
sent or last 10 to 20 years but it is a
growth whoever are creating jobs it is a
growth which is not enough to address
the social deficits that we have
inherited issue of of growth last put at
seven percent by sudden that's the way
we can edit address the basic things but
before we talk about economic
development finances are in silico bed
because I skipped something about
democracy I was at london i was asked
once now that Africa has procedural
electoral democracy what nets then I
said processes systems and institutions
tube address that democracy processes
deliver electoral process normally there
is dispute after elections in Africa it
may be because those who are defeated
feel that they were cheated the only way
you can address that is by being
transparent and ever process which is
transparent and foolproof hence
processes and then systems and
institutions this one I illustrate by
using your own example in elections we
have alcohol and President Bush way
involved unfortunately wouldn't count
all of a sudden in Florida and us start
you are having these question of Florida
having a both way as to kind of
shattered article and so on but what is
important is that it was transparent
bubble and party was here at Democratic
Party there they all turn in their
stories which I didn't buy it but they
were selling themselves it was
transparent the whole world was watching
it that's a process and then when
everything else fails with all our
systems processes system President
Clinton were still a president there
were no armored cars in the streets the
system was working as if nothing has
happened and if everything else fails or
pass fail that you must have
institutions the courts and the courts
must be independent in Africa's case
processes systems and institutions that
we must have two batteries our democracy
I'm given your example what happened
here that you had processes process to
have system and institutions and it was
so good that Americans were appalled
said they will abide by the court's
ruling more so so impressive as i'll go
who said we are government by law and i
would abide by the ruling of the court
they're men good popular vote professor
shots didn't teach you that this mean
that we have a democracy democratic
majority rule mmn got maturity popular
votes but you have also archive system
if we can be allowed to also talk but
you talk about us you have a cage system
a natural college that negates the
people's popular vote so that process is
the one which installed president bush
in a court it's very caught but still
the point i'm making is that you my cell
processes systems and institutions there
for yourself please if you can have
those things which are better doesn't
have all of them have then there is
always a problem fights and instead of
President Clinton being in charge a
system working you make it the armored
cars sold you are taking over that's why
I'm still saying you must have processes
systems and Institute in place
now governance to me the round of the
whole thing is a question of partnership
we must get rid of the days where we
believed in strong presidents
personality cult that some are gods and
that was true basically because some
leaders where icons of liberation
struggle with extraordinary personality
to acquire guruma Sepultura title they
really were forces and therefore their
personalities were salvaged that people
for these black people who are fighting
to free the people against all out
thoughts were inspected and therefore
because of that they became little bit
that their gods demigods so we are
saying now partnership the modern way of
doing it partnership in governance that
partnership is of equals Murphy
transparency and accountability
therefore I planned mathematical formula
it will be known that is to hug again
groups formula that's T plus a equals T
our accountability or transparency plus
accountability equals trust now trans
levels in the world concern leaders is
very low all over the world and it's
because we are not transparent because
we aren't accountable now if you were
are the ultimate sovereigns who say we
are sovereign but unlike Greek
city-states where all people used to
come because population was small and
therefore deciding together all of them
they say now that we are too big in
population who refrain exercising our
sovereignty looking at your manifesto we
are going to buy into a manifesto and
Annette you as our representative and I
will watch you for five years if you
fail I will remove you so people are the
ultimate sovereign they have the power
to remove you and if eaters can accept
that Roberto that people are the
ultimate sovereign and therefore you
will be accountable will be scared of
them but you know the other bosses and
therefore will back on Drupal will be
transparent that's why in a media when I
became a president I started it so where
do we start now from a top that's it it
will be good people talk too much about
corruption and so on we must act and do
a way of corruption if we can do it so I
said first is to start from the top I
declared in my wife volunteered even in
my case is no consciousness requirement
decided to declare all my assets
including it depends i have outside yeah
i used to work for you and by the way
and you and you have to credit union so
I that account i'm going to close it
since 72 but everything because i get
the reports of every month and so on
like you get from Europe end all items I
have and she had we're listed under the
price waterhouse coopers supervision and
declared publicly in front of the press
they would ask questions so therefore
transparency should start from the top
so our ministers those were sitting here
were asked to also declare their assets
the Parliament that is required by the
transition of course we declare their
assets and then the civil servants to
the Prime Minister it has been done I've
seen their assets it's a top secret but
I can say they are very book now we have
to move because I want us to
exchange views in diet around rapacity
who goes in the church and preach those
people who are now tired I had that
before and so on I wanted to ask a
question are not given a chance so I'd
like to give you a trend it will be good
that we can be interactive and I have my
experts will also help me but let me say
to address the issues of poverty of
inequality professor your field Namibia
is the trans which has divided through
bundles and even Africans are divided in
the different tribes and told you of
your own homeland the whites we're
superior they have their own powers and
everything after fighting and we've got
immigrants allege forget that division
and form 1 m-nb our nation I talked
about a million house that you built a
house and I will jump except this is not
a good example for me but I say you
built a house with Briggs and the bridge
I am saying our different tribes ethnic
groups and races and we will
Constitution is our foundation so on
that we are building our house Olivia
have different lives Tamara's namas a
fraternal Germans those our bricks
building blocks the motor to keep that
those breeds together our laws we pass
in the parliament okay to go on you
finish it you let it firm up if you push
that world when I may be a still a young
country even though this cinder it will
collapse but they will firm up then you
plaster you once you have planned study
you will no longer identify individual
bridge it will be there for one wall
that you paint it with a million colors
it becomes a million house in which all
and children must live together white
LED three stripe that's right then I
went on to reflect father you say why
not using this concept to the world so I
say namibia we will Namibian house on
immigrant tribes they become one mb our
nation in Africa we're building African
house where Africans from different
countries will live by using a huge
utter when we have plastered that world
will only see one Africa one continent
parent on Ed day will go to the world
and say we are going to build world
community global village by using all
sovereign states using UN Charter and
when we are going to plaster that wall
we are going to have one world one
people so it's one athlete one mmv are
one nation Africa one continent and one
world one people thank you very much
question
I shot them to death questions huh thank
you very much we're now prepared to take
questions from Columbia students faculty
and Columbia's noted for asking tough
questions so there's microphones on both
sides if you could line up and wait
before you ask a question please
identify yourself your affiliation
whether Columbia or otherwise and while
you're lining up to ask questions let me
ask the president the first question you
have given a vigorous vision of the
future you've also talked about
democracy which is dear to our hearts
you've also talked about building but
building as you said our breaks what
tricks do you still have to build
because you have two terms you're in
your first term so what bricks do you
want to make sure are built in your
institutions before you leave your
office at the end of your second term
I'm anticipating a reelection so I don't
know if you wish to stand or if your
voice is vigorous I have one Tim you are
elected for five years and at the end of
your term if the people want and I want
if I'm healthy that a different thing
but one time and in that one time we set
up what we call approach it that is our
roadmap we call it Harambee prosperity
plan fancy Harambee is a silhouette and
we deliberately chose a ramp a to again
not make people to feel left out other
thing i forgot is that now one muscle
left out in governance if you had only
for one trip one region one race you are
spelling conflict inclusivity
spells harmony so I deliberately took
Harambee so I really where it doesn't
belong to anybody prosperity plan we are
outlining here what we can do firstly
people's needs are great they're black
people especially so education education
that radius equalizer but education not
to come to columbia and get PhD we're a
good PhD because PhD soon our
unconscious with you know suffice but we
went that germans have done artisans so
vocational training who enter setup in
14 regions training institution
vocational training people can work with
their hands that one then to actually
provide conducive investment climate we
have natural resources dymond old
uranium whenever to my town hall
meetings all over the country I was
asking people how many of you have seen
uranium none how many have seemed cold
none time and one such as you see we say
we have our resources person even eat
them but there are some people not to be
people violence is to be people there
Asami would like to have uranium to use
it for whatever they want to come and
invest to take it up give it to them
provide conducive environment they can
come and take it to the advantages not
in our country but we will text them as
a royalties from God money I can build
now plane its schools and highways so
idea is for us to provide conducive
investment climate because government is
not there to create jobs it's a private
sector so a partner a private sector and
many of them were here last week with an
excellent curtain-raiser preparing for
the big compliment we have investor
conference in November and many of the
Macondo Americans mainly because they
are coming because of Chinese
I don't care about that as long as they
can come and invest in Namibia so we
provide investor friendly environment we
are investor friendly people we are
based on laws they were investors I
having rights they can repeat it the
dividends they can take us to court we
lost many cases so that's why can we
raise thank you before I ask the first
person for the question mr. president
let me give you our input to Namibia is
developing that's the friendly it's a
capstone study that we did last year
we'd like to follow it up next year so
on the left hand side please introduce
yourself affiliation etc my name is
nikhil good too I'm an international
student from Kenya in the graduate
school of social work here at Columbia
mr. president how to thank you for the
good work you're doing in Namibia but
before I ask my question I just want to
say that Harambee is a Kenyan word which
Namibians just bored thank you so much
okay um a lot is going on in Africa and
as a social worker I've been involved in
what is going on in countries like
Burundi last year our chapter in
Pennsylvania but involved in the issues
of the suffering of the children and the
women in Burundi because of the conflict
that is going on a president who has
received refuse to live office when it
comes to the African Union when you meet
as heads of state he finds a home and is
comfortable there how comes you don't
hold accountable your colleagues who are
causing suffering to the children and
women of Africa to answer yes
firstly my brother Harambee is a swahili
word it's not a kenyan wait but on
second data use it during youth when
they are amber s but says Swahili word
it doesn't belong to Kenya him sort of
us hahaha but can I use it in second
ever use it recovered Harambee in
talking about moving same direction but
i just used that as a unity in english
does belong to American unity no so I'm
glad you started using it but I'm not
using it and president of Kenya approved
it I said I said in my introduction well
main samjhi because i was i was writing
that you i say we don't take care of
african leaders who oppress their people
or how did you put it yet who uncommon
properly or what I'm saying you don't
hold accountable to your colleagues when
you meet them under the African Union
when they criticized by other people
they rush to the African Union and their
colleagues part them on the back no my
cousin listening to me I said when
somebody comes through illegal means or
so on we are going to kick them out
these days through it they are not
accepted in a you if they came in wrong
way now if you are saying somebody stood
in Kenya and is elected by canyons
democratically democracy is not a
perfect even here so elected
democratically you want men to now say
that was we sit in a you you you are
properly elected or what but if they
come through unlawful means we also size
them we keep them out that's you Africa
you might remember to Africa definitely
but you must know my brother if
Namibians elected me whatever way and
I'm the president
elected by Namibians hey you cannot sit
there and say okay you are doing our own
thing in your country but people are
sovereign I said and those foreign
people sent me there so you must respect
that but when they kill their own people
or they are coming in through a little
mins it's a you is asserted fos east
african community who kicked them out
there are many cases like that until
they have to go and get their house in
order that all we can do dealing with
sovereignty of other countries away you
could never do that in the past but we
are doing it now but i don't know how
you do it too now tell the president of
a country namibia because i quarrelled
with my trade unions and say hey you are
gay you must not treat your people like
that that's not the issue because i'm
elected by the super and sent to a you
but if you come through illegal means we
are taking action against them and even
when there is Latin Capone the last
elections disfrute I'm part of the
committee members who have been set up
from certain Africa I'm a member five of
us are supposed to go to tap on to see
that Tim said all right in the past we
would have never done that we would have
said a scab on his problem leave it to
them so we are trying our best my
brother come back and see I'll take you
around you have been too long here I
think thank you okay thank you very much
thank you Asante sana you don't even
know why you need hahaha I send this one
out una sumus rainy asante sana mirza
una sumus really unix william j ok
hi my name is Miles Mitchell I'm in the
general school study or school of
general studies it's an undergraduate
program here my question is related to
the mining industry which you've
referred to and I'd like to go perhaps a
little bit more into depth and in
reference to your point about the
plaster of Africa it strikes me that one
of the ways that you could create
leverage in the in the global markets
you said for building infrastructure
schools so on and so forth is too I
guess improve the management of these
resources I'm wondering mr. president
can you give us I guess a brief
discourse on what are the real
challenges and dynamics of creating
perhaps a resource management block
similar in kind perhaps like OPEC or
something similar that can create
leverage for African company African
countries to make the most use of
nature's bounty open we are part of open
to every day I drove it so specifically
for non oil yeah no no okay firstly in
our original what you call Rex regional
economic Commission's economic matters
we discussed that but one thing we are
saying is that from now on those who are
coming to invest in Africa must come on
our tents we must have Thames that
determined when you come about
environmental protection because you
just come and dig holes and left so we
are saying we must come on our terms and
we are saying all the tangents in the
world those who are developed had to
industrialize that's realize you have to
add value to your resources when our
saying beneficiation our resources is a
key that way you transfer technology and
you great jobs instead of just coming to
take the stones that Marvel Italy
polished Carter and send it back to us
higher prices so unless realization is
what you are looking at that means we
must add value to our natural resources
and also protect them that
one assembly i'll give you is a fishing
industry namibia is one of the fishing
countries and that industry is properly
controlled enemy bad compared with other
part of the world properly control we
have people who are scientists who will
forget the species and then give their
feature then we have the industry and
the minister based on that will give the
coatis for a year so it's highly
controlled we want to do it that we have
others but the problem we have is some
of these big companies are owned by
foreigners exclusively and that's what
we are saying now in the f that we must
look at inequality that is their
Namibians and africans were deprived
from benefiting from their own resources
and that's resources that makes other
people rich so i say while we welcome
all of you and why people where my
million South Africa we must start to
share ownership must be shared also not
trapping from anybody as I'm people are
reacting here but Professor here is a
key and it any quality if the society is
an equal how are you going to maintain
peace for those who have property
mahanta seat and say we are preserved by
our Constitution considers the paper in
English I said to somebody it might be
internalized by my curative anniversary
telma Constitution we are saying we a
political level have reconciled we
appoint white people in government
ministers class a you have the land you
have the resources also meet us halfway
to share with your brothers who are
still languish in poverty so we joke
about resources only it is everything
it's owned by foreigners in Namibia and
South African see but we don't under war
what I saw that we fought were already
within on the wall we can talk war is
when diplomacy fails so we can still
talk engage our people I have town hall
meetings we have this project kid has
been welcomed by many of namibian see
white that yellow so that's what I don't
know that answer your question but i
thought i would say thank you the orca
thank you if you are not happy i see you
i don't quite happy we admit I've only
expect see a true that one day talk to
thank you once more mr. president for
coming to speak with us here my name is
Kozma a bindi I'm a senior in Columbia
College from Zimbabwe and my question is
on your regional foreign policy and with
regard specifically to static the over
the past few months arm Ian Khama is
spoken out against President Robert
Mugabe and he's deeply for democracy and
human rights record as well as his
personality couch you address this in
your speech but I want to ask why you as
chairman of static in 2011 80 is
president of Namibia it not personally
spoken out or address this issue when
you can clearly see that Zimbabwe is
affecting the rest of southern Africa
how do you know we don't 11 good we
don't go to the public and shout or that
you can be happy and dance in the
streets in New York sorry I missed that
I'm saying how do you now we don't speak
out against know you guys we don't
publicly say it so that you can be happy
and dancing as did see no no no no mr.
president um president Ian Khama came
out last week at a proper press
conference and addressed it right
objectively it's not about jumping in
the street it's just the objective now
I'm sailing to please you while you are
here why Amazon Bob when student yeah I
was studying in the US who's going to go
back to Africa it's not about pleasing
me in the US okay now what I'm saying is
is involved with that President Mugabe
this damn was he elected he has been in
power for 36 years I'm asking history
was elected in an election which SAT
exceed was fair but not 3 was free but
not fair sorry so it's the marbles we
decide not us no you sent
st. observer mission which sees the
election is free but not fair here's
Angie Johnson RS is yours you must go
back and fight we can fight for you we
cannot is he I said if a person is
elected by people of that country and
that elections was regarded as free
elections and now body went into court
to challenge it unlike the previous
elections and therefore we regarded as
sin well one problem yeah Thank You mr.
president I just want to remind you that
there's always the human element to
institutions right courts and supreme
court judges even in the US are pointed
by governments so yes so you have a
system which is been in power for 86
years the Supreme Court judges are
obviously compromised so that's where
regional intervention comes in so that
was my question yes what I'm saying is
that we differ in how we do things we
are going to Swaziland a manner of us
had our own concerns how we are going to
raise it and so on we get a letter from
so-called leaders elders later tell him
us to tell of President Mugabe we are
prepared to anybody we had ideas to see
how to with our head to talk as Africans
our own way and you dragged my letter to
say to enter Booga bear in too long in
office toughest moments but as a
sovereign state I must for in present
karma is doing that at his business but
definitely to me I'll be concerned about
what happens at the prism of Abydos I'll
be concerned what happens after i go
back when President warmest color
consent but will happen when President
pohamba was David we're concerned what
will happen represent that way they will
prepare for it in South Africa happens
and what's going to happen and so on but
I cannot go and fight there and we have
an African way of doing things I cannot
say things to please somebody else and
say I want them to Mugabe now I would
have a way to talk we are we are so
country's sovereign countries but
neighbors and I may say my brother this
thing is it going to work properly
what's going to happen in case this and
this happen we do that we're not going
to stand in a public and shout and say
maccabiah Moscow that's what's imbalance
that for you all right thank you my name
is Tim beam lagi I'm a second year
student at the School of International
Affairs my question has to do with Tim
limits so last year rwanda had a
referendum where the people voted for
their president to extend his term and
looking after hearing a presentation
it's very clear that the respective
institutions has definitely been a very
big contributor to namibia's economic
success and I had the opportunity to
actually see the high quality of life in
the media this year I wanted to get your
thoughts and term limits do you think
they wiccan the integrity of
institutions in Africa's aware of you
know acting as an impediment to
promoting strong governance time limit
I'm the advocate for term limits term
limits for president's executive
producer were elected directbuy people
elected no accountability after that it
helped by people directly because you go
like I do I go in campaign work my
manifesto that you bind we let me I
taught a high percentage then I'm Cena
until next elections so therefore to me
for presidents who I elected direct by
people there must be a term limit and we
have time limit in Olivia for 10 years
but let me tell you one thing I was a
chairman of constituent assembly and I
believe in term limits and after 25 year
terms we had a slight problem and the
president said he had his problem
and I'm not going to tell you all the
problems is Namibian problems and we
said after I listen I said look this is
the Constitution a paper in English only
understood by maybe less the one percent
of people not in generalized if you look
at our army that's a formal abrasion arm
so I said now what I can do leave it to
me what I can do in the interest of
Namibia nobody else is to say the first
pressure was elected by constituent
assembly and sharp there's a
transitional cross and shall serve for
25 year 10 we just put three day and
only two that President the men who
fought was in Bush only to him to say
instead of two we put their three so he
shall save 35 year 10 but the term limit
in a body is contained and as I told you
I am already the third President or
Namibia only 26 years 25 years I am
already the third and very soon one of
the most romantic / so term limits I
believe it but if you are elected like
in South Africa and Botswana through
Parliament or in clear weather where the
Prime Minister comes from Parliament and
you are there in the parliament you are
accountable because the question is
accountability so if you are sitting in
the parliament that prison do matters
you see how ugly it can be and you sit
there and bring question and being
accountable no need for term limits as
it is in England or Canada or so and
because they come through Parliament
Prime Minister's but some presidents are
now being elected by Parliament's so if
they are elected by Parliament they are
countable development no need but etc
president's right here like my my case I
believe strongly in term limits thank
you so much the equivalent of term
limits at the University and in his
schedules so we'll take one more
question sorry so
last question uh-oh thanks hello mr.
president I'm bench and I'm
international student from Shanghai and
I'm a freshman here in Columbia College
so my question is you address the
inequality in Namibia and it is not only
the economic inequality but also social
and corny in terms of for example
antenna land ownership so what I'm
interested in like along with the rapid
rapid economic growth in Namibia they're
also like increasing inequality economic
inequality so I also know that there's a
great ethnical diversity in Namibia yep
so for example like the mature the the
majority of the ethnic group in Namibia
is less than fifty percent of the entire
population so this great urban revolted
by division and also ethnic division
between the distribution of wealth so
what are some ethnic lee targeted
policies that are used in Namibia in
your administration to address those
economic inequality and social
inequality issues thank you very much
inequality as it is a biggest problem
what is bad is it based on color now you
see we had in South Africa is called
black economic empowerment complex are
the ones who left out in this country
you had affirmative action again to see
that some people were left out so we
again typical in Namibia didn't want to
use the word black economic empowerment
kuroko note racial element but very
sensitive to that therefore we talked
about an EF and that that is already
been questioned by some people it's as a
draft document that is trying to see
that the ownership patterns must change
and we are appealing to those who own to
share as I said because if we tested
that we were seeing that we have to
share empower those who
are not privileged enough in the out
country their maturity blessed are
majority in Namibia if you sit on that
you are spelling conflict they will feel
left out you are living at maturity you
are spelling conflict I said inclusivity
spells harmony exclusivity spells
conflict and that's how conflicts are
started but as I said we are trying in
Namibia to include to be inclusive to
discuss for those who are concerned this
plan that we have is approved by many
white LED people plan to hold hands and
within this plan we have projects that
we have worked out well targeted dates
so we can implement it within that we're
talking about length is to attack our
park minding and so on we had the same
you come from Shanghai yeah I am you see
we have a uranium mine which is owned
one hundred percent by Chinese one
hundred percent uranium very sensitive
thing now somehow government must have
some say such a sensitive strategically
so that I look into that that people
came with money they bought because a
capitalist system and they own one
hundred percent even things like uranium
the Chinese company owns it hundred
percent not at you up in Shanghai so you
must tell your government that they must
give something to them even people okay
yeah I'll Jaffa column very good night
much response very good
unfortunately the president also has a
schedule at a problem in Namibia is we
are saying no one must be left out now
they are feeling left out but not by me
okay one question last question I just
like to know about the your strategies
around offshore tax havens given the
mineral wealth that you have how in the
past what's been the experience and
right now what are your strategies this
tax havens other ones were causing
trouble in Africa that says I was
talking in Washington about illicit
outflow of money African money from
mines and so on billions we I don't want
to listen to those things offshore
havens maybe they were meant for good
purpose that time but now is to I the
stolen boots and I don't support it
Thank You mr. president and I must say
I'm very glad i permitted the last
question since I'm teaching a class on
tax havens so it was not a plan she's
one of my students thank you do you wish
to make any closing comments or other
than the fact we welcome you back
whenever you wish to come and continue
the dialogue now thank you very much I'm
really honored to have my friend also
Joseph and all of you thank you very
much for coming out that way Namibia is
a child of international solidarity
Midwife by United Nations friend to all
enemy to none that's an idea thanks
thank you
yeah ladies and gentlemen please remain
in your seats as we escort the president
and his delegation out of the building
thank you
you